[Musique] le
bitcoin
ne s'arrêtera jamais parce que la monnaie fiduciaire
va à zéro et comme vous le savez, dans certains
cas, la monnaie fiduciaire est allée à
des obligations à taux d'intérêt négatifs négatifs,
donc je dis que le bitcoin n'a pas de sommet parce que la
monnaie fiduciaire n'a pas de fond
[Musique]
um
biden's global  l'impôt est
une idée très stupide et
cela prouve que les gouvernements n'ont pas d'
autre politique que de
voler rapacement les gens et
que ce soit l'impôt ou l'impression d'argent qui
cause l'inflation qui est une autre forme
d'impôt,
cela montre que les gouvernements sont arrivés à
la fin de leurs
écoles d'utilité
[Musique]
le dollar fête ses 50
ans d'existence cet été
en août, cela remonte à 1971 lorsque
nixon a fermé la fenêtre de l'or et nous avons
commencé une nouvelle ère
de monnaie fiduciaire pure et donc maintenant après
50 ans, il est clair que le dollar
est probablement  ne durera même pas un
an de plus
dernier
programme de questions
[Musique]
je pense que le problème avec l'alliance us euro
est l'allemagne l'allemagne
je crois parce que la
réussite de  nordstream
2 qui sera cette année en 2021
comme vous le savez, il achemine l'énergie directement
de la russie vers l'europe en
contournant l'ukraine et à ce moment-là, l'
allemagne quittera effectivement l'
otan à mon avis et nous aurons
une nouvelle alliance avec l'allemagne la
russie l'iran la chine
et cela  être le bloc le plus fort
du monde
[Musique]
j'ai entendu parler d'olivier dans mes rêves
là
[Musique]
faire